We Believe fundamentally that food
solves hunger that shelters solve sleep
and that housing solves homelessness and
if we're going to solve the problem of
those that are out on the streets that
we Define as homeless we better solve
the housing problem if we're going to
have an impact and that's why we
establish this framework what we call a
10-year plan to end chronicomas in San
Francisco
oh
foreign
that's why we established this framework
what we call a 10-year plan to end
chronicomas in San Francisco
foreign
Rubin this is the Reuben report and yes
we are back live in studio live
streaming on a rumble YouTube and locals
share subscribe tap that notification
Bell if you have not and that cold open
there was in honor of San Francisco
where I spent a couple days as I am sure
you guys know I went to visit Elon Musk
at Twitter in San Francisco in communist
California some of that video that we
just showed you there in that cold open
uh was video that I actually shot right
outside the Twitter offices so really
think about the the juxtaposition of I'm
upstairs at Twitter offices with
literally the world's richest man I walk
downstairs and it is the walking dead
man these people they are drugged out of
their minds it's absolutely everywhere
we're going to get more into that in
just a minute and I'm going to obviously
tell you all about meeting Elon and some
of the things that I couldn't get into
on the Twitter thread and I just want to
say before we start that I missed you
guys you know I did not plan on not
having shows on Wednesday Thursday
Friday I don't know when the last time
we did that kind of thing was but I got
the call on Tuesday at about 5 00 p.m
Eastern and they were like can you get
to San Francisco right now and we
scrambled and scrambled I sat in the
second to last row 32 e in the middle
and my seat would not recline but I did
it to go see Elon and obviously it was
it was well worth it so we're going to
talk all about that but before we get to
any of that
uh something major happened in the world
that had nothing to do with me nor Elon
nor Twitter uh Finland which is a
country far away Nordic country
you may have heard of it uh something
really incredible happened in Finland uh
there is a 59 year old farmer
uh who is the now first trans
female ice skater and uh he went ice
skating and uh well I don't want to say
too much before we throw on the clip I
just thought I had to show you this
because it's so wonderful when a 59 year
old man can go ice skating as a Finnish
woman
yes
[Music]
foreign
the grace
the Elegance the femininity of that 59
year old male
farmer as a female this this thing that
was the move that's where you could see
she was starting to lose it anyway I
thought it was important that you all
see that it's wonderful for Equity it's
wonderful for diversity and it's a very
exciting time to be a male Finnish
farmer if you've always wanted to be an
ice skater okay let's get to it uh I
went to Twitter so here's what happened
let's show you the first image so the
first image here these I tweeted this
out uh this was after midnight on
Tuesday night I got to the Twitter
offices what you're seeing there on the
left that's just me uh sitting there
obviously I don't know what that little
Twitter box was on the right so this
this office you really need to
understand I'm going to try to paint
this whole picture as clearly as I can
for you uh that is the commissary you
have to remember they had about 7 500
people uh working at Twitter not all
from that office but they obviously had
hundreds and thousands of people uh
working at that office it's a ghost town
now I was there after midnight but they
have fired about half the people there
and also before Elon took over
virtually everybody was working
virtually people just because of covid
and then because they're a bunch of
whiny crybabies who don't want to work
they decided not to go to work anymore
so they build these incredible
facilities I mean they had you know you
get coffee you get wine all the stuff
that you guys know these ridiculous
things that these tech companies do uh
to keep these people there these these
manned children basically or these
children children uh you know they had
ping pong tables and foosball tables and
all of this stuff arcade games
everywhere it's like does anyone work
does anyone work
just to be totally clear we do have a
Miss Pac-Man upstairs and I only let the
guys use it five minutes a day uh anyway
that was the that was the office and
then I went upstairs and I met with Elon
it was a little bit after
midnight he had there were still a bunch
of programmers there he's taking
meetings in and out uh finally he comes
up to me we chat for a little bit and
then he basically says to me not
basically this is almost Verbatim what
he says to me he goes he goes um is
there something I can help you with
right this moment he goes he's like you
know otherwise I'm really tired I was
out all day and it's late and I've been
I've been working for about 20 hours in
a row he's like but if there's something
you really need me for right now I'll
stay otherwise can we do this tomorrow
and I was like wait a minute literally
the world's richest guy the guy's
running Tesla he's running SpaceX neural
link Twitter probably 18 other things
the boring company all of this stuff
he's willing to stay to deal with my
little Twitter stuff like that just
right there kind of sums up almost
everything else that I'm going to tell
you about today the commitment that this
guy has to fixing this thing so
basically I was like uh no Elon you you
could go uh take a nap and we'll we'll
do this again tomorrow so let me read
you the Twitter thread that I put out so
this is going to get into the nuts and
bolts of what I learned about Twitter
and we learned an awful lot oh and I
should preface this by saying that the
way this all unfolded is that about two
weeks ago I got looped in with two uh
engineers at Twitter because obviously
I'm one of the more public people
talking about the fact that something
seems like it's really wrong with
Twitter there was a couple weeks when
Elon got it where the engagement really
seemed like it was the old days it
exploded again and in the last few weeks
it seems very depressed and that seems
very odd like it's like wait a minute
you got Twitter it seems like it was
fixed and now why did it get worse again
all sorts of people usually somewhat
conservative leaning but it's basically
just not woke people are claiming
something's wrong so anyway these two
Engineers started doing a deep dive into
my account and as they were doing a deep
dive into the account I mean really
going into the code they started seeing
things that they had not seen before so
that's why this escalated to the point
of oh Elon wants to see you so all that
being said here is my thread with some
of the nitty-gritty spent the the last
two days at Twitter in San Francisco
talking to Engineers product product
managers and yes Elon Musk learned a ton
about what's going on before I share one
a note that after a couple hour meeting
I asked Elon what I could share and he
said anything that's true Connor just
come back to me for one sec before we
continue on that I just want to hit that
point because so we met on the second
night for about two hours
and it was me Elon had one guy with him
I apologize I I actually don't even know
that I was introduced to get his name
but then it was me Elon this guy and
David Sachs was with us we talked about
a whole bunch of stuff including
politics and everything else and that's
really where he lit up when and I'll get
to that in a second when we talked about
some of my political Awakening which I
think is similar to his but think about
how interesting that is that at the end
of the thing at the end of the
conversation I said look I'd love to
share some of this stuff is there
anything you don't want me to say
anything that's true like and he didn't
have to think about it like he didn't
know what I was talking about with the
engineers I was sitting with Engineers
with their laptops you know two guys
with their laptop coding asking me all
these questions and I'm asking them all
these questions he had no idea what I
had seen so the fact that his default
position was anything that's true
I think that that says an awful lot
about the guy okay here's the thread uh
a fractal Rube Goldberg machine that's
what Elon Musk called Twitter as they
fix the code more problems arise a
delicate balance he likened to a Jenga
Tower one wrong move the whole thing
collapses they're working non-stop and
both times I met him where after
midnight I met with several Engineers
who were doing a deep dive on why my
account and so many others seem to be
absolutely crushed after that two or
three week return to normalcy when Elon
first took over they still have more
questions than answers but they did
learn a bunch of stuff
accounts aren't just hit with labels
that are obvious to insiders they now
found more secret labels which are
causing Shadow bands just so you guys
know this is what they found on my
account and that's why I was called in
my account was hit with all three recent
abuse strike recent misinformation
strike recent suspension strike it's
unclear so far what these strikes
actually do but for sure they suppress
views and recommendations they are
trying to figure out to what extent I
also had many innocuous tweets labeled
NSFW not safe for work or nsfa not say
for ads which affect visibility in the
timeline also there's an entire keyword
database so that machine learning makes
us makes us makes sure not to promote
violence porn Etc but it's a mess of
overreaching words literally the word
gay was on the keyword list which would
make you not Advertiser friendly and
harm the tweet in the algorithm backing
up for a sec they found the recent
suspension strike on my account most
interesting because it was from July
2022 when I was suspended for calling
out Jordan Peterson's unjust suspension
so though suspension was reversed the
action on the count remained on the
account remained Elon was bringing in
people in and out constantly and seems
to be aware of pretty much every issue
he thinks maybe the entire code has to
be torn down and start from scratch at
the end last night he said that the
whole situation is a flaming dumpster
rolling down the street
so I assure you they are aware of the
problems and Elon and the engineers are
there all night trying to untie this
crazy knot some changes they've made
like the For You tab have confused
people and hurt engagement for accounts
who have gotten the nsfa label without
knowing they also don't know for sure
why things got so much better once Elon
made the acquisition and why it seems
far worse now some is probably related
to the excitement around Elon himself
which also coincided with the World Cup
but that doesn't explain why it feels so
off right now we'll share more in a bit
but have to catch a flight on a personal
note Elon is funny as hell laughs a ton
and it's just really obvious he cares
about Twitter because he cares about
free speech and the bigger problems
facing the world he didn't he doesn't
need this headache he chose it also huge
shout out to David sacks who is helping
Elon clean up this mess because he
believes in the fight for his Free
Speech as much as Elon does and massive
thanks to the engineers who opened up
their computers showed me literally
everything I asked for and were total
Pros oh and one other thing for now Elon
really lit up when we talked about the
shifting political landscape out and how
anyone non-woke is now far right that
notion is deeply connected to how screwy
things got at Twitter and he's working
to fix it despite the huge challenges
ahead and then Elon Musk responded to my
very wordy Twitter thread saying
accurate thread okay so there's
obviously a lot there we don't have to
get into all of the nitty-gritty about
the specifics but the most interesting
the banner headline stuff is that they
have now found stuff deep within the
code that is affecting certain people I
gave them a list of a whole bunch of
people all over the political uh the
political Spectrum to look into and they
found various things on various people's
accounts and some some accounts that I
thought would be hit with things they
didn't find anything but really I sat
with these guys
and I don't know if you've ever sat with
like computer Engineers before but these
guys from what I could tell take their
work extremely seriously they're they're
they're so curious as to what's going on
that was the cool thing like to sit with
these guys they're opening up all these
programs pulling information all over
this trying to make sense of things but
as Elon said they fix one little thing
you know he mentioned something that
they had a little bug in Twitter spaces
and they fixed that and then it crashed
the Android app and this idea of course
that he thinks the thing might be so
screwed up I mean this is the most
important communication platform online
whether you like it or not with all the
frustrations we all have with it and all
of those things whether you like it or
not it is what it is
that he might have to scrap the whole
thing and start again and that that is
that is incredibly uh interesting he
also you know he probably has some
people at the company still who are not
Mission aligned with him and he's trying
to fix all of it so now I want to talk
to you a little bit more about my
general trip uh because it wasn't just
going to Twitter and meeting Elon that
was uh enlightening let's say I also
wandered around San Francisco now I know
I do a lot of stuff on the show about
making fun of Los Angeles and making fun
of California and the homelessness and
the drugs and the State of Decay and the
general chaos and all of that stuff but
I have to tell you completely joking
aside with no glibness or
just nothing other than flat out lay it
out here's how it is
San Francisco is disgusting it is a
absolute dystopian nightmare the level
of homelessness there and it's not just
homelessness it's one thing it's one
thing to have homelessness and every
city has homelessness there are some
homeless people in Miami not many but
there are some it is a drug
uh infused nightmare that felt like The
Walking Dead I mean droves of seemingly
gangs of people but it's disorganized uh
uncontrolled sort of craziness people
wandering around with old clothes with
blood on it and it was disgusting anyway
here's uh just a little 15 second
snippet of wandering around town
just enjoying myself stay here in San
Francisco beautiful Town nice weather
everything seems just fine and you know
just
you know having fun
okay yeah you know just enjoy I am not
showing you this to be gratuitous or
anything else I think this what I kept
thinking when I was there is for as much
as some of us might talk about this and
you know you could turn on Fox and they
show you okay the homeless numbers in
these blue cities compared to the red
cities it was mind-blowing to me I lived
in New York City most of my adult life
before my my eight years in Los Angeles
New York City uh wandering around at all
hours in the morning I was never once
afraid like I never once thought I was
going to be attacked or mugged or
stabbed or anything every second walking
around the street you feel it because
it's everywhere it is literally
everywhere and if you get like a 15 foot
uh you know Runway where there's no
homeless people just and it's not again
it's not just homeless people it is
Major meth fentanyl addicts people with
no teeth with with it is just I mean the
smells were horrible everything but if
you get a little Runway where there's
nobody in front of you for 15 feet then
there's just trash everywhere and
needles and all that so this is a video
that I took we just showed you this in
the Gavin Newsom thing at the at the
open but this is me just walking I just
put my phone out I cannot believe I
walked through this thing probably not
the best healthiest idea to do this but
I actually walked through this this is
basically about
I don't know 500 feet from Twitter
offices so you quite literally have the
world's richest man upstairs and then
downstairs this is what you have
and this goes on and on and on and I kid
you not here I mean here's just some
random pictures that I snapped that guy
asked me for 20 bucks the one with no
pants on the left uh the other guys over
here I was some I mean it was just nuts
like I can't even explain this properly
but I really I was wandering around
because my my meetings with Elon kept
getting delayed which is why we ended up
meeting so late so I just had you know I
could wander around the city during the
day and I went to Sunglass Hut which was
in what I thought was like a pretty
decent area but it's it's sprawling it's
absolutely everywhere and I'm going to
link this obviously to everything that's
going on politically today and
everything else but I think it's
important that you see that it's crazy
to me that that's not on television
every day for these for these liberals
or these lefties Or democrats who think
that it's you know it's that factory
settings nonsense Democrats like people
and Republicans like money right like
that's what these people actually think
and if you think for a second that those
tolerant and diverse progressives that
run that City you think they care about
people look what they have done to the
people and it's not just the drug
addicts and the homeless people that
they have ruined life for I I kid you
not when you see people walking in San
Francisco almost everyone walks with
their head down you're never going to
see anyone smile I assure you that and
there is there is generally a sense of
Terror an absolute sense of Terror I at
one point
because my meetings were getting delayed
I realized I had to eat I was like all
right I have no idea I might be in with
Elon for six hours I better read
something so I could not find a
restaurant to go do because everything
was so disgusting that I was like all
right let me put in my phone I'm just
going to put in Steakhouse because
usually you'll find a steakhouse in a
somewhat decent area so I went to go to
Mastro's Steakhouse if you've ever been
to Mastro's every I've been to mastros
in Malibu and mastros all over the place
they're pretty freaking fantastic you
know high-end steakhouses I walked there
it was oh that video we just showed you
of all the homeless people think that
was me walking over to mastros I walked
there and outside there's basically Four
Guys cooking something and it wasn't
steak cooking meth or fentanyl I don't
know if you cook fentanyl or whatever it
was but and then I just was like no
forget this I'm not going in there I had
dinner at my friend's house thank you
buddy
um it was it was just unbelievable
anyway as long as I was in California
for the two days I thought you know what
I'm gonna stay here for a day or two
I'll do some stuff down in LA with
prageru and I'll say to hi to a couple
remaining friends pretty much everyone
has left so I did go to Los Angeles and
I have to say before we show you
anything from LA
compared to San Francisco Los Angeles is
Shangri-La it's a dump but it's
Shangri-La compared to San Francisco I
went in I needed some hairspray needed
some hairspray so I was going to go to a
CVS over there I tweeted this one
walking into CVS in La anyone know
offhand how much stuff you're allowed to
steal without getting prosecuted trying
to decide which hairspray to snag we did
a little research on this what did it
turn out to be guys 950 bucks you are
allowed to steal I mean really think
about this in Los Angeles now I did pay
for it I got some sort of Garnier
Fructis gel I didn't even get a
hairspray it was about nine bucks pretty
solid I would say a good deal I did
decide to pay for it because that's just
you know I'm an upstanding citizen of
these United States of America but you
are literally allowed to steal up to 950
dollars worth of stuff and they will not
prosecute you that means if you live in
Los Angeles you can walk into Best Buy
Ai and you can take a PlayStation 5.
Connor how much is a PlayStation 5
rolling for these days about 500 bucks
so 500 bucks how much are the games now
probably 50 70 bucks for a PS5 game so
70 bucks let's say you took five of
those games right now you're at 350. you
could you could get six games
according to my math that's going to get
you to about 920 bucks you can walk into
a Best Buy take a PlayStation 5 although
I know they're very hard to get so you
may not even have one there uh and you
can get six games and walk out of there
and they will not prosecute you and and
me this schmuck paying for my own gel
just craziness anyway there's been a
whole bunch of other videos I could have
shown you a bunch more from La we'll
just we'll just do two that have been
going viral uh these were not shot by me
uh but I did comment on them just to
show you and you'll see why again I'm
not doing this to mock homeless people
I'm not doing this to be gratuitous we
are right now at a really interesting
Divergence in America we are at a fork
in the road and it's becoming more and
more obvious which way will we go will
we go woke and socialist destruction or
will we go Freedom loving and capitalist
loving and decency and all of that stuff
so here's a video from Los Angeles
that's been making the rounds take a
look at this one
what
what dude you guys you have everywhere
man
you gotta you got a baseball bat you got
yours
hey I'll send it to the cop
what the
wow
look how look how crazy they are
you guys when's the city you guys when's
the city gonna come clean this up
is that propane
I hope you guys are pissed off I'm
pissed off that they threw my car
that guy has a cell phone what the
is going on
we're going to show you one more of this
but you really need to understand again
this is sprawling all over the city I
actually had dinner uh on Friday no no I
had dinner on Saturday night I know
dinner on Thursday night man it was a
crazy trip I had dinner on Thursday
night with some friends in Hollywood we
were at a extremely nice restaurant
actually but outside it's just it's just
insane it's just that and it's
everywhere and and what's so interesting
about this is think about these last two
and a half years of this Bizarro Matrix
that we're living in we have constantly
been told about public health we we
quarantine children and we didn't let
people visit dying relatives and we
forced people to wear masks and inject
themselves with all this stuff do you
think that the people that are in charge
of LA or San Francisco are doing
anything related to Public Health can
you even
let's just say this was all about covid
you have all of these people doing drugs
with no sanitation like it's just
absolutely insane here here's one more
and then we're gonna get to the other
way you can go on that fork in the road
[Music]
so it's everywhere guys you get the
point okay so what what does this mean
if you're watching this and you're going
all right Dave I see it I get it these
are these are big government policies
these are blue run cities and states uh
what do you do what do you do well there
are simple answers it does not have to
be this way but it is consistently this
way when Democrats take office because
they purport to like people but
apparently not those people and I don't
think they like themselves very much but
that's a different psychological topic
we'll get into another time but why are
San Francisco and Los Angeles like this
why did a guy like me
leave Los Angeles and move to a place
like Florida which if you would have
said that to me 10 years ago I would
have said that you were insane well
there's a very simple answer to it it's
good governance good governance rule of
law doing the right thing and doing
basically the things that we all knew
were saying say 10 or 20 years ago so
what's going on here in Miami well you
may remember a couple months back I
interviewed Miami mayor Francis Suarez
on why Miami is flourishing and why it
is not the dystopian nightmare that we
just showed you from San Francisco and
Los Angeles
the the flourishing is every day I wake
up and there's a new Los Angelino coming
to my town now I'm starting to worry but
and I've been in an elected office for
13 years so maybe there's a correlation
between the 14 and the 13. but look I I
think uh you're right I always say
Miami's an idea it's more than a city
and it's an idea born out of a trauma
what's the trauma the trauma is many
people in mind were kicked out of their
country most were exiled uh because a
leader in their country said give me all
your businesses give me all your
property don't worry we'll make
everything equal and you know what they
did they made everything equal equally
miserable for everybody right and so we
are traumatized by that and I think
that's why miamians are so fundamentally
pro-america we're so fundamentally Pro
uh you know sort of fair market and free
market and we believe in freedom and
liberty right we believe in freedom and
liberty our
parents our grandparents know what they
fled
we're doing it right here and we have a
diverse City in the true sense of
diversity not that that even matters I
would not care if all of my neighbors
were white or all of my neighbors were
black or half of them were Cuban and a
quarter of them were Venezuelan and then
we had some bolivians and some Asians I
wouldn't care if they were decent
citizens that's the thing that is the
American dream nobody really cares what
you care about is hey you came here or
somebody before you came here are you
going to work hard are you going to be a
decent citizen are you going to work to
not destroy this this tenuous experiment
of Freedom which is not the default
position of humanity you only have to
look at the history books to look at how
precious this incredible free experiment
that we have running right now not sure
how much longer it's going to last it's
like this is freaking precious what we
have right now the default position is
to have authoritarian leaders and
dictators and have most of the people
living in filth while the elite live in
their castles but we are doing it right
in some places and I continued with
Suarez he talked about why other cities
are going that direction while Miami is
going in the right direction
so how does it make any sense I thought
you the government just needs more of
our money to make things work but you're
keeping taxes low and so and we don't
have you know roads exploding and all
sorts of stuff yeah yeah it's it's so
counterintuitive how is it possible so
let's let's let me give you a real
example right if you are living in New
York City right now cost of living
differential between New York and Miami
is two to one so in New York the median
home price is a million dollars in Miami
median home price is 540 two to one
right in addition to that in New York
you're paying 50 if you're in the
highest tax bracket a lot of New Yorkers
are because again your cost of living
well they're all coming down here now
well but check it out let's do the math
right you're paying 54 cents out of
every dollar in taxes that means that
for every dollar you earn you take home
46 cents in Miami you get 63 cents right
it is a huge Delta so what's happening
now in the United States is very similar
what happened to Detroit at the
Industrial Revolution right which is
that you're seeing this change from
industrial to digital and Miami is the
only city in America that got the memo
and has basically built its entire
economy to capitalize in what I call a
tsunami of opportunity and cities like
New York and and San Francisco and
Silicon Valley thought they were too big
to fail and I'll tell you Dave they're
not okay one more time guys I'm not
doing this to be like oh look how great
it is I moved to the right place and
blah blah blah I'm doing this to show
you there there is a blueprint I always
talk about the wider Florida blueprint
related to DeSantis but it's also
happening at a city level and then it
happens at a town level and eventually
below that it happens at a at a
community level and hopefully a family
level and then believe it or not you
know what it all boils down to the
individual level that's how this thing
can work you know I texted mayor Suarez
right before the show started I said I'm
gonna I'm gonna say a couple nice things
about you on the show today and about
Miami he just texted me while we were
playing that clip you know how many
homeless people we have in Miami I mean
this is wild guys 640 and he said he's
working to make sure that we'll have
zero he wants to figure out a way but
the thing is our homeless people here
our old-fashioned homeless people
they're not zombies they're not whacked
out on crazy drugs of course there's
some level of drugs here but the drug
thing this fentanyl thing I mean that
I'm telling you I saw something that is
very uh that is much scarier than what I
really thought this thing was and I
thought thought it was pretty bad a
couple numbers just to give you a little
context so we have 640 homeless people
in Miami right now 70 000 in Los Angeles
20 000 in San Francisco I'm pretty sure
I shook all their hands on my walk uh
and there's about just under 600 000 in
America as a total
so there is some real stuff to talk
about here okay and I just want to say
one other thing about mayor Suarez
because look at this picture the other
two weeks ago Dude I don't remember if
we showed this on the show but two weeks
ago I take the team out for dinner uh
our our intern Joseph was visiting I
took the guys out in Coconut Grove over
here we had a great dinner and then I
just bump into the mayor he's just
wandering around saying hello to people
a lot of outdoor seating in Miami it was
a beautiful night he's literally just
smiling and shaking hands with people
and and as I tweet it what did I write
there I said something like uh date
people often say Dave what's really the
difference between Miami and Los Angeles
in Miami you bump into the mayor
wandering around with a huge smile on
his face saying hello to everyone in La
the mayor can get you 20 off crack on
the street corner and just I don't want
to do any misinformation here apparently
she can get you 25 if you know somebody
okay that's Karen bass she'll get you 25
off your local crack if you're in Los
Angeles so apologies please don't delete
me okay so why are these why is is this
Divergence happening and and why is it
widening by the second well it's pretty
obvious one side has decided that
competency has nothing to do with how
you will hire people it has nothing to
do with whether you will bring in the
best Engineers if it's at Twitter it has
nothing to do with whether you'll bring
in the best public servants if it if
it's in the government it's all about
ideological possession that is their
total that is the sum totality of what
they believe in they believe in identity
Beyond everything else and if you don't
believe me here's black lesbian press
secretary Karin Jean-Pierre explaining
that uh yeah uh it's that
um I'm certainly not going to get ahead
of the president that is not something
that I can do from here but look and I
kind of set it at the top the Biden
Harris Administration is the most
diverse in history that is a fact and we
expect to uh we expect this trend to
continue uh the cabinet is a majority
people of color for the first time in
history the cabinet is majority female
for the first time in history the
majority of white house senior staff
identify as female 40 of White House
senior staff identify as part of
racially diverse communities a record
six assistance to the president are
openly lgbtq
nobody cares about any of that
well I can't say nobody I mean I guess
you guys care but no sane person cares
what we elect you people to do
is hopefully keep the wheels on the car
right we have a car it's going down a
rickety Road all we ask that you guys do
make sure the wheels
stay on this thing because the road's in
bad shape we're about to go over this
this bridge that thing's kind of banged
up uh could we do that and what they do
is hire based on diversity and she's
really proud of that like that is the
Pinnacle of her success and it's the
Pinnacle I would say of the Biden
Administration success they have
majority people of color in the cabinet
now that that's kind of interesting
because we don't have a majority of
people of color in the country
um so are you guys discriminating
against white people actually you are
but somehow in your world that's not
discrimination they've I think she said
majority female I think she said
majority female identifying cabinet I
female identifying and it's like you
know we're the ones that hate women it's
so stupid it's so stupid but again it
goes to nothing about their expertise
Pete butterjudge was the mayor of South
Bend Indiana it's a tiny little city in
Indiana and then they made him
Transportation secretary there were was
probably thousands of people who are
city planners and Engineers who have
worked their entire life
so that they could have a job like
Transportation secretary really look at
the map of the country figure out what
roads need to be fixed do we need to do
High-Speed Rail here what's going on
with the airlines what can we do related
to competition can the government get
some regulation out of the way so we can
fix some of these things you know we're
working on an international tour in May
that hopefully I'll have some more info
about soon and we were looking at some
flights last week and it's incredible to
fly from country to Country in parts of
Europe it's as cheap as like 65 bucks
like I was trying to put together the
budget for this thing and I'm thinking
okay I'm gonna have to buy all these
tickets for all my guys I don't know is
it a thousand bucks a seat to get out of
the some of these countries 65 bucks it
cost me I think it was 800 bucks to get
seat 32e in the middle to go to San
Francisco from Miami last week so many
things are screwed up but that doesn't
matter guys we've got gay Pete he's gay
it doesn't matter he's gay
here's more from Biden and diversity if
you hire people based on diversity you
will not hire the best of the best what
I would like you to do is hire the best
of the best I don't care if our
transportation secretary is Indian I
don't care if our defense secretary is a
lesbian and I don't care if my God if we
hired a white person the scariest of all
things but we do something else we hire
incompetent people based on diversity
here is Dr Fatima Cody she is the Biden
Administration Deputy of Health for 2025
first for this current Administration
and she's talking about the current
dietary guidelines and I just want you
to listen to this woman and you tell me
if she's the best of the best
if you diet
you lose weight
right the number one cause of obesity is
genetics that means if you are born to
parents that have obesity you have a 50
to 85 percent likelihood of having the
disease yourself even with optimal diet
exercise
sleep management Stress Management so
when people see families that have
obesity the assumption is what are they
feeding those kids
okay lady first off is there some
genetic component to obesity obviously
but do you see what they want you to do
they want you to think you have no
capacity over your own life they want
you to think that if you drink a 64
ounce Coke with all of that sugar and
you eat crap all day and they lock you
in your house and you don't exercise
well you have no ability to control any
of these things do you know what you do
have ability to control it's your own
life it's the one thing that you can
probably control on this Earth you can
control how much you eat how much you
exercise but they want to diminish those
things it's why we spent two and a half
years of covid not talking about hey get
some exercise that that obesity is the
highest comorbidity related to covid we
we told people stay at home order in all
the time don't do anything right we CL
we literally close gyms we closed
beaches we told people don't get vitamin
D don't walk out there these people are
all incompetent but sometimes every now
and again it's worse than just
incompetence the same people who see
racism everywhere well I should say
racism everywhere except where it
actually it is actually is they bring on
people like ilhan Omar ilhan Omar who
married her brother
Google it it's true eventually they'll
remove it from Google she married her
brother she is a really awful person she
has been all for defunding the police
she is absolutely destroyed Minneapolis
she hates America despite being a first
generation immigrant who moved here from
Somalia became incredibly powerful and
she spends every day trying to undermine
this country that has been far far too
good for someone like her well she was
on CNN yesterday talking to Dana Bash
and Dana asked her about her previous
anti-semitic competent comments and
here's some double speak for you
so when you apologized uh for the all
about the Benjamin's comment you said
anti-Semitism is real and I'm grateful
for Jewish allies and colleagues who are
educating me on the painful history of
anti-Semitic tropes what did you learn
a lot
um I certainly did not or was not aware
that the word hypnotized was a Trope
um I wasn't aware
um of of the fact that there are tropes
about Jews and money that has been a
very enlightening uh part of of this
journey
yeah it's been so enlightening of course
she knew exactly what she is doing she
she's just a VI like there's nothing we
can do with these people
like there's nothing we can say about
them that would shame them and then Adam
Schiff and Adam Schiff
I did not I wasn't sure of this I had to
Google it he's Jewish and I just like to
say as a Jew we apologize if I have to
write a letter to somebody and just like
we don't want anything to do with Adam
Schiff I'll gladly do it but he sits
there knowing he is sitting with this
vile racist woman and he does not say a
word but how hilarious is that's what
the panel on CNN is it's Adam Schiff
Adam Schiff who completely made up the
Russia collusion hoax who now is running
for Senate he's a congressman he's now
running for Senate in Cali so we'll
probably get him it'll be even worse in
California you have him you have Eric
swallow was the other guy sitting there
he's the one that slept with the Chinese
spy and you know it's true because the
media refuses to debunk it and Kevin
McCarthy keeps saying it and then you
have ilhan Omar who basically is an
islamist and and at some level is at the
very least I mean she's deeply
anti-American she defunded the police in
Minneapolis they destroyed Minneapolis
and then she blamed the police for not
doing their job on top of marrying her
brother and a whole bunch of other stuff
these are awful awful human beings right
they really there's just no other way to
say it if that is what you use your
power for I don't know how I can
describe you anyway so do you see what
I'm getting at their priorities are so
off they're so far off that they're
automatically by default damaging the
very people they govern and speaking of
another one of those people here is New
York Governor Kathy hokel and I cannot
believe that this woman I know I call
her Kathy seaward usually I cannot
believe that the people of New York
reelected her but they did and they will
now get what they deserved she still
this is this weekend she still will not
hire unvaxed health care workers even
right now with everything we know take a
look our Health Care Systems seem in
desperate need of Staff right now we've
had ambulances waiting five hours at our
local emergency rooms to unload patients
the hospitals the nursing homes say
they're waiting for Doh guidance on
whether they can hire any of those
workers back what's the latest with that
it's a problem but I don't think the
answer is to make have someone who comes
in who's sick be exposed to someone who
can give them
Coronavirus
given covid-19 I don't know that that's
the right answer in fact I'm pretty sure
it's not it's so all right guys we're
getting demonetized that Botox has
no idea what she's saying okay the fact
is that if you get the vaccine you can
still get and transmit covid more people
who have gotten the vaccine have died of
Kobe than people who have not and if the
vaccine worked and someone walked in who
was unvaccinated then the sick person
the other person would not get sick
right it's all so extraordinarily stupid
but they keep going they cannot that
Botox that's a good line we're
gonna we gotta use that one again
um it's just endless with these people
someone please if you are in New York
and you're sane and I know it's a thin
little sliver of people that we could
say that about I have a couple family
members that are pretty decent but like
someone sue the hell out of her the idea
that the governor is saying we will not
hire unvaxed people while they're having
these shortages while uh ambulances are
backed up and emergency rooms are
overflowing and every everything else
it's like if any of that is true and
that's what you're doing somebody Sue
this woman put her on the penal colony
of urapente
that's a Star Trek reference I think it
might be the first one I've ever made on
this show
this guy John Campbell got a close-up of
uh of her necklace look at this thing
the woman walks around with a vax
necklace tell me this is not a cult but
speaking of Cults here's Bill Gates
admitting that vaccines don't work and
that's why we need more of them anyway
so antibodies antivirals
we think we can also have very early in
an epidemic the thing you can inhale uh
that will mean that you can't be
infected a block or an inhaled Blocker
we also need to fix the three problems
with vaccines the current vaccines are
not infection blocking uh they're not
broad so a new variants come up you lose
protection and they have very short
duration particularly in the people who
matter which are old people and every
one of those things is is fixable in
fact doing that work is going to help
vaccinology very very broadly
vaccinology I didn't even know that that
was a word okay fine what does Bill
Gates have to do with your health how
did he become this person that we are
supposed to listen to about all of these
things when by the way we've shown it to
you many times before we have all of the
video of him lying about everything
related to the vaccine that it works
that you won't get over that you won't
Translate
you get all of it and they just keep
marching on that when I talk about how
these people are evil and soulless and
everything else it's not just because I
disagree with them politically I might
have every disagreement with them
related to abortion and taxes and
foreign policy and everything and you
can have principled people on both sides
of an issue you could have confused
people on both sides of an issue but
these people who get everything wrong
and then they just keep marching forward
despite reality that is something
twisted and evil I don't know of a
better uh I don't know how to describe
it better than that but it just keeps
continuing so the other thing that
happened while I was gone this is wild
stuff and you are not seeing this on
mainstream media and you must understand
if the mainstream media ignores
something if they ignore something you
must know that it is real this is
exactly what they do and and to even
prove that so you know I go to Twitter I
release this entire thread which with
pretty incredible stuff related to
what's going on at Twitter do you think
anyone covered that at CNN or Fox News
or anything else no but if you go and
you go on CNN site and you search Elon
Musk or you search Twitter you're going
to find all these hit pieces about him
but then when people find out
interesting things about the code the
code that was supposedly used by Donald
Trump to manipulate the election with
Russian Bots uh they go crazy about that
but when reality hits they ignore it so
ignoring is becoming the number one type
of fake news that's one thing okay the
other thing that I missed while I was
gone is that project veritas
which you guys all know project Veritas
and I've I've had uh what's his name
I've had uh James O'Keefe on the show
um they do great work uncovering uh
basically they get they do they do spy
videos people have accused them of
manipulation a whole bunch but a lot of
the stuff that they do is quite good
they sat down with a guy at a restaurant
named Jordan tishton Walker he is
advisor director and he basically said
that yes they do want to mutate the
virus meaning they do want to mutate
covet and other viruses so that they can
keep people vaccinated this is and then
just watch this whole thing this is wild
Pfizer ultimately is thinking about
mutating covet well that's not what we
say to the public no don't tell anyone
foreign
[Music]
yeah I know me Jordan Tristan Walker a
director of research and development
strategic operations and mRNA scientific
planning advisor it sounds like gain a
function to me
it's like this
it's definitely not getting a function
it sounds like it is I mean it's okay
no directed evolution is very different
or you're not supposed to do gain
function research with the viruses like
yeah exactly not but you do like things
like selected threshold mutations to try
and see if you can make more Pokey yeah
so they're the areas research I'm going
about that I don't know how that's gonna
work we're not being more outbreaks it's
like Jesus Christ this is absolutely
wild this guy is a director at Pfizer
fact okay he is doing research with the
MRNA vaccine fact and what he talks
about there is something called directed
evolution
directed Evolution this is gain of
function and that's he's playing these
linguistic games around it gain of
function when you manipulate right what
do they want to do they want to mutate a
virus they want to gain a function of
the virus so you have a virus I mean
this is this is just like basic stuff
you have a virus that's out there then
what were they doing at Wuhan they were
studying how do you manipulate that
virus to gain a function of that virus
so you can do something else whether you
want to weaponize it or anything else
but they play all of these linguistic
aims so when the guy says to him that uh
directed Evolution sounds a lot like
game uh uh gain of function he's like
well not really but then you know he's
laughing through it and he kinds of
admits it and if you want to link this
to our earlier story where we started
today remember when everyone kept saying
for years what you guys do with Twitter
is Shadow Banning and what uh Jack
Dorsey testified was we do not Shadow
band so when the Twitter files came out
you know what they called it visibility
filtering so it's the exact same thing
whether it's directed Evolution gain of
function or visibility filtering and
Shadow Banning it is the same exact
thing so anyway this guy is now being
exposed these are his words right these
are his words he's being exposed by
project Veritas and then James O'Keefe
walks in they have the aha moment and
then all hell breaks loose
hey there is this seat taken you work
for Pfizer my question for you is why is
Pfizer want to hide from the public the
fact that they're mutating the covet
viruses I'm literally a liar I was
trying to impress a person on a date
don't touch me well this is not why the
way don't tell anybody who's just
working in a company to literally help
the public
you really did please
can you please unlock your door no no
don't let them leave please unlock the
door
please unlock please unlock the door
please unlock the door
lock the door
unlock the door unlock the door I mean
it's like to catch a predator it's wild
but anyway look more and more will come
out of this of course but this will
continue that Divergence that we have in
society much like the Twitter files
there will be a whole bunch of people
who see that video Who start thinking
and knowing that Pfizer is interested in
gain of function research and there will
be this whole other set of people and
it's a shrinking set of people which is
the the white pill on all of this right
it is the good news on all of this the
Silver Lining on all this uh that will
just take what the machine gives them
and the Machine intentionally ignores
the truth so what is it that these guys
have to do well as I mentioned project
Veritas and James bookkeeper just back
on Twitter because Elon brought them
back they were suspended a long time ago
do you think they were suspended because
perhaps the government had been working
with Twitter to suspend people is that
such a crazy conspiracy theorist is that
like so crazy to think that I'm not so
sure so what do they do they have to
make sure that they ignore certain
stories but they also have to ban people
which is why they ban project Veritas
it's why Robert Malone was banned and
it's why I was banned for saying
mandates were coming and it's why Jordan
Peterson was banned for saying that uh
who who was it that had the penis that
got the penis back and then well Ellen
Page was Elliot page or any of that
stuff so many stupid characters in this
idiotic play that we're in it's hard to
remember all their names you know
anyway here is a New York Times
journalist her name is Mara gay uh of
course of course her name's Mara gay uh
this is a woman who once said that the
Reuben report was a white supremacist
talk show she said that in the New York
Times I did not I did not know that uh
here she is on MSNBC freaking out
because Trump's going to be allowed back
on Facebook you don't want to whether
you're a company or an institution you
don't want to hand over the keys to
democracy to have someone destroy that
democracy dude so do you want to be that
Institution
that uh really helps take down the
country
ah so letting Donald Trump back on
Facebook will help take down the country
Donald Trump who was president for four
years and we had a great economy we had
all of these Middle East peace deals
signed our border was way more protected
we had other countries paying their
share into NATO and the U.N and a whole
bunch more if we bring that guy back and
we let him post on Facebook we're going
to destroy the country I don't think we
need Donald Trump to do that I think the
Democrats and the corporate press and
everything else are doing just fine on
that right but returning to Twitter and
linking this with the coverage of the
left and and the disaffected Liberals
that I'm always talking about what we
need to do is expand this blueprint
right the blueprint of what's working in
Florida which is also connected to The
Bravery of someone like Elon Musk who
remembered the lifelong Democrat had
never voted for Republican until he
voted for Myra Flores Because He Lives
technically he lives in in Texas
um but now has said he will support Elon
Musk what we need is the whole bunch of
sane people to come together take the
blueprint of Florida export that and and
let's see what happens so right after I
met with Elon Musk to bring this whole
thing around uh the very next morning he
was hopping on a plane that night even
though I left him at probably 1 30 a.m
or something he was hopping on a flight
going to DC and here's who he was
meeting with yeah he was meeting with uh
McCarthy That's Right leader McCarthy
right there and they were meeting he
also for the record he did meet with
Hakeem Jeffries Hakeem Jeffries is the
leader of the Democrats in the house but
here is a guy
who is just fighting for free speech who
has extraordinary influence and power
and he's meeting with the Republicans
and the Democrats to to hopefully ensure
that places like Twitter social media
companies and where our information our
information is sourced from and pushed
out to the world that it will be more
impartial uh I wanted to show you that
picture specifically because as I've
been saying for the last two or three
weeks I think the Republicans are
turning right now I think they are not
going to be as ineffectual as usual I
think they are going to do everything
they can in the house at least to cut
the funding for Stuff the house can't do
everything without the Senate and of
course the Democrats still do have the
Senate they can't do everything but they
can do an awful lot so the left left
Elon Musk and you know what the left
left another guy I showed you this tweet
once yeah the left left Jordan Peterson
too I wasn't a conservative until
liberals kowtowed to radicals ain't it
the truth and speaking of Jordan
Peterson uh Jordan Peterson was on a
very small podcast on the computer
machine you may have heard of this thing
it's called The Joe Rogan Experience uh
and he was on a couple days ago and they
started talking about what's going on
with the world economic Forum what is
going on with these people who meet to
decide that top-down layer of we control
you down there I thought this was quite
good
I've been trying to understand the
driving ideas underneath this globalist
utopian tyranny that seems to be
developing from the top down and I think
it's driven at least in part by this
religious Vision that I already
described you know that you have to
construe culture itself especially
industrial culture as the tyrannical
father raping and pillaging everything
in its way which is unbelievably
dangerous way to think to one-sided and
uh the the the idea that you have to
impose limits to growth on people in
order to have a sustainable planet and
so when I look at ideas like that that
first assumption you know the planet has
too many people on it it's like I don't
like to hear people say that because
when I hear that I think okay buddy who
exactly are you thinking about getting
rid of oh well it's not like that it's
like yeah it's like that it has to be
like it is absolutely like that like
I've already felt that I'd be that war
for the last six months and I would say
it's War because what I observed
happening in Europe when I was there
last was that well you can see this you
don't have to be in Europe to see it but
it's more direct if you're there is that
it's pretty damn clear that the
globalist utopians are willing to
sacrifice the poor for the sake of the
planet it's like that'd be fine with me
not really that'd be fine with me if the
consequence of your actions raising
Energy prices for example actually prove
produced an improvement in those things
you wanted to improve if you're if
you're a cure for the planet is well you
know we got to put 350 million poor
people in Jeopardy just so that things
are hypothetically better in 100 years I
think yeah I don't think so buddy and
also it's a little bit too convenient
for me that your prescriptions to save
the planet are accompanied by this
insistence that the only way forward to
that is to give you all the power it's
like there's a bit of a moral hazard in
that don't you think it's like I'm just
saving the planet give me all the power
it's like you want to save the planet or
do you want the power and let's let's
put the first the second one first
because the probability that you're a
saint or the Messiah is pretty damn low
oh man he's good he just gets it he's
good
um look this top down thing it ain't
working and we must fight it and I love
that Jordan said I feel like I've been
at War for the last six months you know
I I happen to know Jordan pretty well I
think he's been at War for a lot longer
I think we're all at War at some level I
think this Divergence that I'm talking
about uh it's going to lead us to a very
weird place so we need more people to
come down the path that I'm trying to
lay out for you guys right here and I
think it actually is happening but when
you see that when you see a guy like
Jordan Peterson now fully saying the
Liberals went bananas right when you see
a guy like Elon Musk telling people
before the election vote for Republicans
not because he thinks they're so great
but they're better it's like that means
one side has gone completely crazy and
how I wanted to close the show today
there is a guy he is a Soviet KGB
Defector he's long since passed but in
the 80s he was putting out a lot of
video those from lectures that he did
his name is Yuri besmanov you may have
seen some of these videos they go viral
every now and again and he describes
exactly how the Communists the
Socialists the Soviets would destroy
America from the inside and one of the
things that he focuses on most is how
you'd go after the kids you'd go after
education so you could just you don't
have to shoot uh guns you don't have to
drop bombs you don't have to invade you
could actually destroy young people's
minds and then with a little bit of
patience you could take over a whole
country here's one little snippet of
that you'll see it's a little pixelated
right up front but then it does clear
itself up
education
distract them from learning something
which is constructive pragmatic
efficient
instead of mathematics physics foreign
languages chemistry teach them history
of urban Warfare
natural food
uh
home economy your sexuality anything as
long as it takes you away
okay uh social life
replace traditionally established
institutions and organizations with fake
organizations
take away the initiative from people
take away the responsibility from
naturally established links between
individuals group of individuals and
Society at large and replace them with
artificially bureaucratically controlled
bodies
instead of social life and friendship
between Neighbors
establish social workers
institutions the people who are on
payroll of whom
Society no bureaucracy
the main concern of social workers is
not your family not you not social
relations between groups of people the
main concern is to get the paycheck
I mean it goes on and on we'll play you
more clips from him over the coming
weeks but what he's describing there is
exactly the thing that Jordan Peterson
now says he is at war with it is the
exact same thing that we spent a whole
bunch of time over the last two three
weeks talking about at the world
economic Forum it's not about
individuals it's not about personal
responsibility they want to break down
all of those things and they don't want
social interactions they want social
workers you will be a worker you will be
a piece of the machine nothing more than
the Cog and then a cog in the machine
I would prefer not and I think you would
prefer not and we got work to do but
nothing better to do than save the world
guys it's me Monday over at the Reuben
report locals Community uh I put up a
Babylon bee headlight I just thought
this was perfect in light of everything
that I've been talking about today
having maxed out taxes on California
residents Newsome proposes new tax on
Florida residents yeah nice try dude uh
as always guys we have a post game show
which I'm really really enjoying uh
doing the little slightly more relaxed
just getting to know you guys a little
bit more and just doing a lot of that on
we do a lot of this on the fly but doing
a lot of that on the fly as well you can
join us right now we usually go for
about 10 or 15 minutes at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with former Secretary of State
and former head of the CIA Mike Pompeo
is up right now and we leave you with a
very this this is of all our cold cold
closes this might be the most disturbing
ever and I'll see everybody else in
about 47 seconds
[Music]
thank you